so thank you everyone for coming my name
is John foltz I that I'm the director of
user interface development at Wolfram
research and what I'm talking about
today has nothing to do with that so I'm
talking about integrating it with the
Wolfram language this is kind of a a pet
project that I began sometime last last
summer early fall and has turned into
some really interesting technology that
we've been using internally we're not
shipping it yet but but i'll talk more
about that a little bit if you don't
know anything at all about get i'm
afraid that my talk will probably not be
very enlightening to you i welcome you
to stick around anyway but but i have a
half hour and i have a lot of material
to cover and bringing people up to speed
and get can't be done under a half hour
even under the most ambitious of
circumstances and also i'm going to not
take any questions until the end
hopefully i can get through and we'll
have time for questions but i really
want to try to get through a lot of
material here but somebody yell at me if
the screen goes out or something like
that okay so i will give a very brief
introduction what is get but this is a
60 second introduction that probably
will still leave you lost if you didn't
know what it was before so first and
foremost get is a version control system
if you're familiar with CVS or
subversion or perforce that's what get
is that's that's its purpose in life
it's decentralized and this is very
different from a lot of the older
systems like CVS and subversion what
that means what it means be
decentralized is there is no central
server that you have to deal with
I mean you may have a convention of
people using a central server but but
all the information you need about the
repository lives on your system and and
when you're making commits you're making
commits to your system you don't need
wires or wifis or anything of the sorts
so get represents commits and not just
commits but also directories and files
relationally to one another in a
directed acyclic graph and the and each
of these things commits directories and
files are there basically objects and
they live in an object store and when
you look in in a git repository if you
have a repository on your system and you
look in the hidden directory the dot get
directory most of what you'll see in
there is these is these objects which
are which are kind of anonymous because
they're indexed by by hexadecimal hashes
which which which are shaws and MP and
people in the get world refer refer to
them as shaw's quite often so if you
want to identify a commit uniquely you
can identify it by cha so that's the
basic introduction of what we're dealing
with oh and I say here commits trees and
blobs a blob is just the object store
version of a file but it's stored
without a file name the file name is in
the thing that index is in ok so just a
little bit of a visualization here so i
have a very simple repository here and
let me i can't keep it this magnified
for the entire talk but i can do it for
this slide so the here is a simple
repository that has three commits in it
now the first commit is actually the one
on the right here which is the commit
that has no parents
and and you can see this commit has
metadata attached to it it's we know
that it's it's an object it's an object
of type commit it points to a tree and a
tree is basically what we think of as a
stuff that we put into into virginal
it's a directory that will contain files
or other directories it has information
about when the commit was made by whom
it has the Shah of course and then the
commit log and there's some other
metadata in there too but that's that's
the principle bits now we can actually
kind of dive a little deeper in here i'm
using the graph functionality which kind
of relayed this out a bit oh and i
should have said i should have said so
that was the first one but then this
second commit the second commit here
this has a new piece of metadata as a
parent that points to the first commits
and so i'm representing that as graph
here and so these green blobs here are
these green rectangles i should say our
commits and each one of the commits
points to a tree and so I've exploded
and you can see the tree here and so in
this case the tree is for this
particular commit is something contains
a single file just read me.txt and then
I make a change here in this one I added
a second file and this third one also
has two files but one one of the blobs
is different I made a change the one of
the blobs and I won't belabor the point
too much but you can see here the
relationships so so this blob is
actually being used by two of the root
trees there as is this one and this one
is unique to to the final tree down
below so that is the basic idea
so why access get from the Wolfram
language well you know wolfen language
we like to call it a symbolic language
what does it mean to be a symbolic
language it means that data and code or
you know totally the same and you want
to treat your your data like it's code
you want to treat your code like its
data that's fine and one of the things
that we built on that is is you know
thinking of our tooling as being fully
accessible from the language as well and
this is the one place where I can play
the part of the front-end person because
you know that's what the front end is
you know the front end you know could
have been just you know a stupid editor
that you know does maybe some very
impressive stuff but is not accessible
from your code but in fact it's fully
accessible this and a lesson we learned
that this is really useful so being able
to access your tools from your code is a
known good in terms of version control I
mean we're looking at get because get is
basically the unchallenged leader there
are lots of people who have various
problems with get you know in terms of
usability or whatever but but very few
people would argue that today and for
the foreseeable future in terms of
mindshare get is definitely the leader
and something that's been missing in
version control for a long time is the
ability to support merging of notebooks
notebooks are structured documents and
and version control you know use this
kind of standard dipping sorts of
algorithms which look at things by lines
we're not structured by lines we're
structured by expressions so so having
integrations so that we can actually
achieve you know a respectable emerging
of notebooks is important and it turned
out actually that we as a company made
the made the switch to get over the
course of the last year and it turned
out that having having this set of tools
available to
us was really valuable for our internal
tooling and I'll go into the few details
of that a bit later so basic
introduction and this is you know it's
just in addition to the language it's
and in most cases i try to keep things
fairly close to the command line so you
you know you'll recognize things pretty
quickly there are a few places where i
make a few differences but i don't think
they're worth dwelling on too much so
how do you get to a repository so you
can open a repository and when you do
that you get a typeset thing behind that
types that thing is just a you know a
rich you know association that describes
the object that it was that it was
pointing to you can also clone something
and i'm doing a local clone it simply
because i didn't want to you know
potentially have network problems here
but but everything works fine on the
network to with certain modes of
authentication or you can just create a
new repository completely from scratch
and here it created a directory that
didn't exist before and and so i'm going
to i'm going to use this our new for the
new repository for a bit here to just
show a few things so what can you do
with a repository once you have it well
you can get its properties and so here
are what the prompt what the typical
properties of a new repository looks
like depending on how you created it
might be a little different but but
that's the basic idea so the and we can
see here it is empty that's the most
important thing right now we can also
take a look at its status and there's
not much interesting in status at the
moment but i'll come back to that in a
second so let's let's put a file in that
directory okay so i'm just taking our
new and you know kind of an association
fashion I'm just passing the working
directory to it to get that and so I
just you know put a file in trivial file
but now if we run git status now we see
that that we have something sitting in
there okay so get has a system which
takes a little getting used to wear
unlike many other version control
systems you you don't just commit
everything that's in the repository or
everything that's in the working
directory you you have to add and it's
not really adding new files it's adding
changes so you made a change you need to
add that change to to get it ready to go
into your commit so and that goes into a
place called the index so we run git add
and we do get status again and we see
that it's moved from the new area to the
index new area and now we can do a
commit the commit includes includes log
message here and it produces a nice
little object for us and we can get we
can get a properties on that and we see
this is very much the same sort of thing
we saw in that earlier slide with the
dataset tooltip that I popped up and in
this case we see a timestamp that
matches with about 10 seconds ago so and
at this point now if we go back to get
status we will see that the get status
is now back to empty again because
status is looking at the changes
relative to whatever your head commit is
and we do have a head commit we didn't
have one before but we sure do now and
and now it's telling us that head is
pointing to the master branch which is
master is kind of the default branch
that get uses so I also have a notion of
get close it's not necessary to use get
clothes but sometimes the the library
that we're using for accessing get it
sometimes will lock down some resources
which if you want to like
delete the directory or something like
that it may be impossible to do so get
close is an optional thing but something
that you can do okay so some more
advanced concepts you can access
arbitrary revisions okay so here I'm I'm
not referring to the new repository I
created but I'm referring to another
repository I created I opened which in
fact is the repository that I've been
developing get linked in so we're
actually looking at some statistics you
know some commits and such from from the
object that includes this code is very
meta so here we go I'm just saying give
me the commits which represents the
master branch in that repository I can
also say give me a range of commits well
so that I'm once again I'm saying master
when what it what it understands is Oh
range of commits you mean everything all
the way back to the beginning of time as
long as there is a parent-child
relationship going back from master it
will be uncovered here so you might want
to do something a little more flexible
where you want to kind of mix and match
ranges and so here's something that's
very common in get is the ability to say
this branch but not that branch which is
to say that I want all the starting from
this branch I want it and all of its
ancestors but then strike out all the
ancestors of this other branch so in
this case i'm looking at a branch that i
have standard notebook merge and I want
to find everything that's on that branch
but it's not on master so things which
are unique to that branch relative to
master and in this case it's for commits
and deed if i graph those commits and
the branch was called standard notebook
merge and we take a look and we see ya
this is this is a commit from Lou
d'andrea and it kind of looks like it's
implementing standard notebook merge so
did the right thing okay so some more
advanced concepts
you can access trees and blobs directly
and you can do this from the gate
command line most people don't but
actually I've discovered since adding
this functionality that it's become very
natural in some cases for me to do this
in the Wolfram language so in this case
I'm just accessing the the root tree for
the master branch in the get link
repository which doesn't look very big
it doesn't look very big because it
points to a bunch of other trees so each
one of these trees is a sub-directory
and if I just take that the second the
second guy there which is a blob and
then I can just read that and it just
brings it back to me as text and get
reblogged can actually not just read
text but it it has import running behind
it so you can pass it any import format
that you want you could have it reading
and displaying PNG's for example okay so
so with that is kind of a background
let's let's do a little coding here and
let's let's try to do something
practical and you know a nice small
problem but one that would be kind of
difficult and you know trying to do from
some other language or from the command
line or something like that let's let's
find some wine counts of of what we have
in the repository so so first we're
going to start with getting the object
that we want and so there's a commit
object that object we need to get the
tree that it points to and so there's a
tree and then what we really want to do
is we want to get everything inside that
tree so we can do get expand tree it
takes a second argument which is kind of
a level spec and so will give it an
infinite level spec and that will
actually then give us you know expand
all the subtrees end files so everything
down here now is a
Bob okay and we don't want all the blobs
I couldn't linecount the entire
repository that's not useful I want to
line count let's let's line count the
the C++ code so so we'll select that and
we will do look for a string match q and
string max Q of so we have the name
field in the Association so we're
matching name against and we'll have to
choose pattern here and let's let's say
a string pattern of something that ends
in either dot cpp or dot H okay oops and
there we go and let's see if we get
something a little more reasonable here
that's given us something different and
yeah it looks like this is this is C++
files there cpp and dot H files ok so
let's okay so let's get us down to take
we just want the list of blobs from that
okay and there we go there's our list of
blobs which represents in the master
branch every file ending in cpp or h and
okay so that's good and I put that code
basically here so so this much and then
it built a little function out of it so
a get line count function which does
does this if it gets an object that
looks like a commit and then it calls
itself recursively and then when it gets
an object that is blob it it basically
just does something very
simple it's probably could be done more
efficiently but get read blob string
splitted length okay so let's do that
and line count and there we go that's
about right that seems plausible okay
good so let's do a time series so I'm
actually writing a time series over the
entire set of commits all 272 I think of
them it wise and this takes just a
little bit to run but but should be
coming out any time now and we'll go
ahead and do the date list plot of that
as well and so this is you know this is
very straightforward code I mean you
know you know we wrote half of it while
I was standing right here and and this
is taking longer than I expected this
wasn't take there we go there we go okay
and so I'm gonna have to skip a little
bit here for lack of time this there is
this artifact here which was which was
due to the fact that the data is not
clean because there was you know some
extra code that had gotten copied in at
an early stage and I have some slides
here that talk about how to how to find
the actually no you know this is I can
run this comparatively quickly so what
i'm doing here is i'm just looking for
you know anything that's over 6,000
let's just look for anything over 6,000
entire history and let's just see what
what commit objects those were and then
and then we'll take a look at one of
them and we'll see what the outlier was
why the data seem so odd right there and
when we do that we'll find that we look
here oh yeah you know that's right
because at some point for convenience
sake I had copied math like da Chen and
that's kind of throwing the data off so
and it also copied in wolf and library H
as well so
run this right now but you can see it's
kind of very simple we can just rerun
the original thing with you know just
removing the line counts for math link
that H and for wolf and library down H
and there we go and you know this is you
know this whole process running through
this took me about you know 20 minutes
so very easy to do and I have a couple
other fun little examples here which
I'll show you very quickly because I am
running low on time so this is in 13
lines I I built a browser that allows
you to to look at files and open them up
or whatever and choose whatever branch
you want to look at and then that was
too easy so so then I built a browser
which allowed to allow you to take two
branches and then see what the
differences were and so you know here's
the case where you know the differences
are in orange so you know inside the
gate link directory there's a difference
inside there there's difference inside
both documentation and Colonel you can
you know take it all the way down and
then if you end up with a notebook at
the end you can even you know open it up
in using the notebook diff tools so okay
but you know this is kind of fun but it
really it's solve real problems for us
the when we migrated from CVS it was a
hard difficult task and it was the tools
that we had didn't go all the way for us
requires some significant
post-processing I wrote it all in the
Wolfen language the we also find
ourselves kind of routinely doing you
know having kind of script ability needs
one of the examples is you know we use a
pull request model so there are a lot of
named branches flying around they don't
always get cleaned up so having having a
way to automatically find feature
branches which have been merged and
clean them up we implemented a really
interesting tool which which also helps
us to automate dealing with Mo
multiple repositories you know Google
did this twice they did it with Android
and apparently they failed so badly they
did it again with chromium and we did it
once and we're happy with it so so go
Google and and also we created a very
interesting way of doing deployment at
development branches into nightly builds
which I will go into the details but but
basically allows us to be you to keep
our master branch clean this is part of
what has allowed us to ship new features
every two two and a half months for the
last six months okay and yeah we built a
thing it's very impressive it works you
know it's a it's a nice interface and
fifty plus developers using it every day
so we are eating our own dog food here
when you get it it will be heavily
tested so three-way notebook merging I
wanted to show this real quick and so
this is okay so we have we have our
notebook here so if this is this is the
base version of it the and then the
version which is on master the version
which is on on our feature branch and
then merging you know despite the fact
that there were changes over the place
merging not that much of a except it
didn't update did it oh look at that it
didn't update for some reason okay ah
there we go sorry it was evaluating the
wrong thing there we go so yeah and so
there we have our three-way merge been
waiting for this for you know 15 20
years okay so when's the shipping large
amount is already done mostly it's about
getting the functionality that you know
we have the functionality that we needed
needed but it mostly it's about trying
to cover more you know enough get
functionality for it to make sense for
people to say yeah now I can do
everything I need to do and get with it
some of the details I've talked about my
change before we ship i'll update this
talk to reflect any changes what do you
mean update where you're going to find
it oh yeah we have we have a github
presence this talk is on github not
difficult to remember github com and
then after that Wolfram research so this
talk is repo number one in the wolf and
research organization more to come